you just flew back from New York seeing
your goddess Cher
what was that you guys like I am NOT
paid to promote this you know I love
cher but let me tell you something that
Cher show was the best show ever you
have to go see it like it was so so so
so amazing them this pull part about all
her wardrobe and Bob Mackie and his
characters in it and just even after the
show cher came on stage she started
singing I mean these actors that there's
three girls that play Cher they are so
good Kim did you cry I did I actually
cried at one point and I'm like I had
this makeup on and I'm like trying to
not let the tears come down I mean it
was really sad she she said so much
about her life and was so open and
shared so much well so it was
interesting because you know she's half
Armenian I'm half Armenian so her story
of how she felt kind of out of place I
just I always really connect with Cher
so I'm the biggest cher geek well we
know you are and here's the thing Kanye
goes from checking his phone which we
all do to saying that you guys were
singing along like was Kanye transformed
by cher as well I mean he has always
heard me talk about her and used her as
reference so honestly he was on his
phone taking notes he definitely wanted
to apologize for being on his phone
because he's like I get it I am a
performer I would you know I would love
people when they're in the moment but he
was like taking stage notes and taking
things and like in his phone so I get it
he was like I'm gonna work on my
etiquette but he loved the show and I
thought like oh what a nice husband he's
just coming to like support me and like
has no interest and he was up there like
singing her songs like he was like
definitely into it so it was really cute
I loved the intern you know and really
like love what I love and stand for
share with you yeah
[Music]